what did you think troy
of matrix yes i let it wash all over me
and it was it was glorious it was
far better look i was i was not
anticipating something um i i i'm
i like all the movies yeah all right i i
think two and three are are gr
you shut up
wow i think the two or three my mac just
restarted um i i think that two and
three one once you put them into the
context of of a lot of what was
happening and if you look at them as
just straight movies
yeah if you want to just look at matrix
matrix reloaded and matrix uh um uh wait
reloaded and you once yeah revolution
revolution is the last one the
resurrection is a lot i gotta get
confused um
i i think yeah i could look to see how
you could be like eh they kind of didn't
do as well as i wanted them to between
two and three however if you put them in
the context of what was happening when
they were filming them
the wachowskis are are amazing they were
so far ahead of their time oh yeah um
i
what's what's interesting is that one of
the wachowskis is missing from this
latest installment it's just lana
wachowski correct um
so
i'm not sure
why the other wachowski decided she
didn't want to be a part of this there's
a reason for that um is there because i
didn't know yeah i looked it up because
i was curious um there's no reason it
happened they're they're just missed
phone calls yeah just
shows they're making sure
tonight
no it was that um
it was very linked to them emotionally
with i believe their parents dying
and lana uh expressed that she felt like
it would be good for her to to make
something
um
that has a theme of love i guess is what
i would say of did their parents die
back during the time of the old films
subsequently recently afterwards and
uh the other wachowski um had said that
she basically didn't
didn't want to she wasn't in the space
where she wanted to revisit something
like it was just that they this is how
they as creatives
i understand that by the way it's it's a
simple google thing i just cannot
remember i keep it's like
i feel bad for not being able to
remember i just remember leonardo
chowski because i just saw it on screen
um so please forgive me for for not
being able to remember um
her sister's name i'm also getting her
sister's name unfortunately uh
i never knew their names at any point
because it was always just no way
yeah so it's lana and lily
lana and lily thank you so lilly
apologies uh for not remembering your
name um i
known listener of the show huge strategy
but they put the phone down it's like
we're about to call that said after this
movie and and i also recently saw uh
speed racer
the wachowskis have shot so high up on
my list of creatives that i would love
to sit down and talk to just to be like
what went into making this how do you
storyboard speed racer and like how do
you work on on big budget properties and
just clearly get to do whatever you want
like i feel like the way they work is so
interesting well and especially watching
going back and and this is a wonderful
opportunity it's a wonderful reminder
there are people that were not really
alive or really
aware of this franchise we were so
spoiled in the early 2000s because we
had uh you know kicking off in 99 we had
matrix and then we had lord of the rings
we had harry potter you know now it's a
little bit uh there was a time before
the mcu there was the time before the
dcu there was a time before
all of these huge mega franchises where
people just kind of expected something
of it to be on a big screen x-men the
first
ryan singer x-men came out in two
thousand three
two thousand two thousand yeah um and it
was like novel it was like a big budget
superhero movie right because before
then you had had you know tim burton had
had his run joel schumacher had come in
and done his destroyed it all destroyed
everything um but yeah it's superhero
movies and and big franchises and what's
so funny is if you haven't watched
equilibrium which uh
matrix far out shadowed but equilibrium
was a it's kind of the same premise a
little bit more leaned into more of like
a huxley and uh uh dystopian future kind
of thing it's it's you would dig it as
well and and uh
the ip in some ways is is very cool the
world in the matrix is far better but
the ip and the idea behind
equilibrium is really cool you should
check it out but i i i love the
animatrix the animatrix helped after i
saw matrix and before two came out my
next door neighbor at this apartment
that i lived is like have you seen the
animatrix i said no he goes come over
right now you got to watch this it
reframes everything and so watching all
of those things
um there's this beautiful anthology of
of different uh creators the guy who
neon flux did one for for the thing it
went so much more into backstory and
world building and gave you more context
that i went into two going oh plus
there were two people that died uh
during the filming of of matrix reloaded
and one in between um revolution uh the
original actress who played uh the
oracle um
she died so so all of a sudden you have
this pinnacle character that you have to
go
we have to recast or we have to change
our story and they decided to lean into
the fact that it was different instead
of doing two darins and never mentioning
it at all they leaned into the notion
um and also the original the perfect ip
to be able to pull that off they
certainly got lucky
to like it's very believable under the
story framework of the matrix that
someone would change appearance i think
from the outside looking in sure but i
think that witchowski's as you said a
lot of being able to go how do we fix
this takes such an incredible level of
skill
uh narrative and and storytelling to be
able to go and even still people were
like that that was stupid i'm like do
you know what they had what they were
fixing like they had to completely
change the character it totally altered
and led the charge it it became such a
cornerstone of the story and in the
animatrix they go into even more of it
and there's stuff that's in the game
that that talks about it as well and the
beauty is is there get ready kids this
is what we're in for today
the uh you asked for this
um there's so much of the story that is
told and what i love is that they
inserts no one asked for this no
they didn't
um
the
the fact that they were already
uh the wachowskis were already showing
it's not about like we could have an
entire podcast
talking about um the different
characters in the side characters ghost
um uh apoc and and everybody else but
but especially of watts and and and how
they were a binary character non-binary
character
um
or switch sorry the switch yeah switch
so
uh i don't have my you know my my bible
up right now i'm interested i'm going
off in memory but the if you watch if
you go and play the game and people have
heard me talk about this before too that
was such a beautiful thing because it
wasn't like oh we need we should also
probably do a video game to tie this in
and and find another cash grab and
revenue stream for this it is here is a
completely different way for us to tell
a totally different story that sits
parallel to this one
and i believe lana wachowski also worked
on the um unreal demo
the matrix
and i think that's also really cool
right that i do not feel like these two
are people who care about
cash grabs the closest to to that
impression that i would get would be
jupiter ascending which uh very much
feels like twilight it is the three
twilight movies put into one movie in a
way that's like it's so similar that it
feels like you were trying to do this um
and i'm one of the people who kind of
enjoyed jupiter ascending once i
accepted that it was super silly
it is supercilious
um the thing that i mean they
intentionally it's not that they took
stuff that they cut out of the movie and
put it into the game they shot stuff
specifically for the game
so that it would look the exact same and
that to me is what i want to do i want
to show that you can have something that
has like last of us part 2 graphics that
is also on netflix and is also on in a
game and tell the story in two different
ways um using the same not not like
here's a film adaptation of a game it's
like no use the same exact technology
and i think the unreal five demo for
matrix showed you can do it because
everyone's like damn that looks real so
i think that we're getting there but but
being able to put all of that into
context and and understanding that the
original choice for captain naobi was
actually going to be uh aaliyah and she
tragically died um
in between filming and so they had to
recast and they got jaded pinkett smith
in there
there was just so many obstacles that
they overcome and overcame and i i
really applaud them as filmmakers for
being able to
as ryan holliday puts in his book the
obstacle is the way that that became
this like oh here's an opportunity for
us to tell the story in a different way
and they did it so going into this new
movie i was ready for anything and from
the very beginning i was just laughing
going absolutely why not
yes and they did a great job of
making me question everything they did a
great job of presenting it in such a way
that their the story that they were
telling i was 100 into uh i want to
applaud keanu reeves
because this doesn't say anything but
just like the first coffee shop scene
um
he was lights out he was lights out his
his his just subtlety and response
was so endearing um i thought he was i
forgot
everybody was expecting him to be john
wick
but just playing neo and it was the
total opposite there was no badass about
him no it was just it was so so good the
fight scenes were incredible i would
rate it thus i would go one four two
three wow with that with without
including yes
fundamentally disagree with you on the
fight scenes i think the choreography in
this movie was the thing that i was
disappointed by
okay feels like a lot of really fast
cuts and not a lot of like very cool
action i felt like the the fighting
would almost felt like it was made by
somebody else
um i didn't i definitely think it was
probably a different fight choreographer
because the original fight choreographer
was yeah it was master ping i believe
that's who it was and they just seemed
to cut around it it's like it wasn't uh
it wasn't a spectacle it was just there
um i found it like very underwhelming
and at first the the the premise at
first which yeah we will try not to
spoil this
at first i was like annoyed by it
because there was all this terminology
that i was like
these people don't speak like that this
is infuriating to listen to um
but then
as it delves into what's actually
happening and i was understanding why
they did that i actually thought that
that was brilliant and i was very
entertained by it and i think there are
like some things that i don't love about
it i understand
criticisms that it's interesting you
don't have troy because i didn't have
them as someone who's not like lifelong
matrix fan
that the events of this film undo
previous films in a way that people
didn't like um
but it for me it was mostly like as soon
as i just was like i'm here for whatever
this law is i got super into it i was
like oh this means this and this means
that no that happened because of this
and i just like got very very into it um
while thinking
i i i don't want to get too far down
that rabbit hole
but i am curious as to what events it
undoes because i didn't to me there
every time i was like yeah but you
forgot about this
but it worked undid the sacrifice made
it meaningless
no this is the beauty of it this is how
i can look at it and go people are like
they're trying to prop him up as a
messianic character like yeah absolutely
they're they're using that which by the
way jesus is not the only one there's
multiple
um iterations of of that's a criticism
levied this film yeah i mean that was
the third film that like it wasn't even
subtle uh well how could you criticize
that about this without also criticizing
the third for the same reason without
giving away too much it basically is
obviously we have a fourth movie which
means it didn't bring about the end of
the war right so there's there's now
this is still continuing
so the thing that i i loved about that
is
if if you want to lean into the
messianic role of that and and using the
traditional form of jesus jesus did the
same thing he was supposed to save the
world on the cross that was the whole
thing and here we are two thousand years
later and we fight more still sinning
till sending till synon
[Laughter]
we need to go back to wine troy
[Laughter]
um
so i i i i it's an interesting criticism
i i just i look at it as far as
narratively
look i mean once you flip
the el gato i am then the metal box
yeah it's a fun thing to play with it is
a fun thing to play with once you flip a
ducati in midair and have trinity you
know do the splits in a bad way and beat
guys up with their helmet and then bash
out the window in 120 frames and have
bullets go through you and all that
stuff i i didn't need to see that
anymore what i wanted to see was better
story not better storytelling but more
rich storytelling i
i think your relationships are very rich
yeah and i really liked the look i feel
like there are things about this movie
that i thought was sort of bad um but i
didn't care
uh and it was very interesting that
austin i think that i was benefited by
going in the same expectations that you
have my twitter timeline was full of
people who i usually agree with saying
it was the worst movie that they'd ever
seen like and i was like i was like okay
come on
twitter i know that it it makes us
exaggerate our opinions on things
because that's the best way to get
engagement but i was seeing like my eyes
were bleeding as i started seeing people
be like if you like this movie uh you
have terrible taste and you're
irredeemable like really intense and so
i was like this is going to be terrible
and so i went in and i was like you
deserve death kind of um so i was
pleasantly surprised by being into it it
was like i i wouldn't say that i felt
like it was a great film however i
really enjoyed it so isn't that it's
serving its purpose and again it made me
go damn the wachowskis um
yeah i was a very big fan of how they
explored relationships more than
anything i think it's worth
remembering that people said the same
thing about the second and third films
too uh they were they were seemingly
despite being successful films
they were
seemingly universally hated and the
matrix is the classic
go-to when people want to say
you know
there was no need for a sequel the first
one is perfect they sullied it out a lot
of i remember at the time kind of
feeling a bit neutral like back in 2003
or whenever they came out and thinking
you know there's plenty that i like
about these films there was a lot i
liked about the films but i also
remember thinking i don't i wouldn't
have hated if all we had was the first
one it's just no perfect
um
but i remember maybe 10 years afterwards
so give or take
10 years ago
i went and did like a triple screening
of the three
films
and i remember thinking
relative to
the run-of-the-mill summer like
transformer movie
these are way way more ambitious films
than we're used to for a summer
blockbuster and
history
history had made that feel all the more
striking when i watched
you know the so-called bad ones of of
reloaded and revolutions i was like
these films are imperfect and their
story logic seems to me to be flawed but
they are aspiring to something that most
movies don't even aspire to that yeah i
would i would rather watch a movie that
doesn't quite stick the landing but
tries to get another flip in the jump i
mean that's the way i felt about
spiderman was that i was like there are
some logic leaps here that i've
initially found very annoying i was like
why would they do this this doesn't make
any sense i don't buy that he would do
this
this is such a dumb risk i don't buy any
of it then i was like alana it's a
spiderman movie it's a blockbuster enjoy
it for what it is and then i was like
okay this is great it's funny and it's
absolutely it's warm you don't have to
pick apart the logic and i was like just
let it stop and then i was fine
the first time i i agree but i also
don't feel i just feel it's it's
incomplete to go
uh they just didn't do some of the
things they wanted to use did you see
all of it because i really do feel
and this this is the thing that i almost
applaud the wachowskis for the most
they presented their story in five parts
now six
and if you didn't if you only saw three
and you judged they're like fine that's
some [ __ ] strength that is like some
resilience and some spine of of a
filmmaker to go
they may never know
but we did what we wanted to do and that
started from frame one like the first
thing they shot was the opening of the
movie it's the first thing they
storyboarded and it was if you if you
see the boards for it they're like we
want
a comic book feel we want this to be
like the comic books that we read they
framed it as such they blocked it as
such they shot it as such and so they
knew going in where they wanted this
where they wanted this to go i don't
think that they went in knowing we're
gonna do five six parts they were gonna
do one and then it was successful enough
for them to be able to go now where do
we take it and that's when everything
fell apart but it's not that it didn't
fall apart on their side
i don't feel and i think that if you
watched all you'd be like oh [ __ ] all
right because one of the best things
about it spoiler alert if you haven't
seen the animatrix or not is watching
the first three or really the most
important the final flight of the osiris
and then the the two
history ones but you realize we're the
bad guys we're on the wrong side of this
and that to me just shines or just casts
a shadow over everything that makes
everything else makes sense
i [ __ ] love these movies i i left the
theaters the first movie that i've seen
in the theater since covid
and wow
i went
i came home and i was like i want to
watch this on hbo
and pam was like no we're going to watch
something else i was like okay
[Laughter]
i'm reading
oh go ahead
i was just going to throw in some trivia
about the new one that is interesting
the original
has
one of the standout
scores
i would argue in cinema uh like it is
it is one of the most memorable and
strikingly original
scores
of all time
i mean that yeah the whole
but to me it all boils down to the
trumpets doing the
can't really effectively do that on
piano i love that you tried you went for
crescendos you know
yeah such a great gesture
so elegantly simple don davis who was
largely unknown uh
until doing the matrix um
and just completely
crushed it um
and then wrote really really really
great scores for the second and third
ones as well arguably
arguably building on it in a way that
was even
better
but
but
noteworthy didn't particularly get along
with the wakowskis
and
they never worked with him again
like speed racer is jaquino jupiter
ascending was jaquino
and for this one
they well i guess lana hired
um
a composer
uh named uh johnny
uh clemeck who is well known as a
partner a co-composer on a lot of films
with a guy named reynold heil and they
did the movies of a director named tom
tipper like runlola run and perfume
and uh cloud atlas which the wachowskis
of course were involved in
um and um
the but what's interesting is tom tipper
is the director but they also the three
of them
had like a band together and so you
would see like on a movie like perfume
ton tickfur the director is credited as
one of the composers and so what was
especially interesting to me was that on
the new matrix resurrection tom tickvar
while in no way related as a director is
one of the composers of the new film so
this is a person who has directed major
films but is now sitting purely in the
composer chair that's cool interesting
uh on the new matrix and along with
johnny clemeck but curiously i don't
think reynold heil i don't know why that
is um so two of the three
um
on this one and i found that to be i was
like i don't know
the only time i can think of of ever
hearing of that happen was this one time
when you know clint eastwood typically
at least before would score his own
films as well that he would direct
um
and there's only one instance of him
scoring a film that he didn't direct
which was this
movie called grace is gone with john
cusack
uh from about 20 years ago or no no not
quite more like 15 years ago which was
it made it made headlines because they
fired another composer and and clint
eastwood replaced him it was like it was
like what is going on and there's a
whole story there i don't want to derail
a soft matrix but anyway i thought it
was interesting i thought i misread it
at first when i first looked up uh the
matrix whenever however many months ago
to see what they ended up doing in the
end for music and i saw tom ticker i was
like interesting the director
uh who's like a noteworthy director uh
you know perfume i think is a freaking
awesome movie um
and um
uh anyway i i haven't i haven't seen the
film i and i intentionally didn't go
listen to the score yet so i'm purely
this is purely trivia of credits i
haven't i can't speak the score is good
i don't remember which is not
necessarily probably
yeah no i mean well that's always the
age old debate is the best score the one
that you don't notice yeah because
you're so immersed or is the best score
the one that you're humming on the the
drive home from the theater
star wars they're both right yeah
there's so much about like it wasn't
just for me it wasn't the just the score
but it was also
rob zombie and how um
like going into the the first
uh the very beginning of the first club
scene
you know that that just [ __ ] four on
the floor white zombie and the um is it
the chemical brothers during the hotel
lobby uh
yeah it was good to go
dude you know what was so cool is in the
the original dvd of the matrix had um
like the there was the director's
commentary audio channel but then there
was also a music
commentary audio channel that isolated
the score so it removed all the sound
effects and and dialogue and and so all
the score cues were isolated to picture
on their own and in between those don
davis would talk about like this okay
this cue that's coming up you're going
to hear it starts with the trumpets and
a lot of need give and as like you know
seventeen-year-old me that was like
under watching austin
for real it was such it was such a it
was such an education to get that like
deep dive into a single work and such a
noteworthy work there's also if like one
of my favorite going out of that dracula
um
they do something that's so subtle where
they uh pulse the sound of the alarm in
early and so that it gets louder and
louder and louder than isolates so that
you realize it's the alarm waking him up
it's just to me that the thoughtfulness
of how these two worlds are intertwined
yeah i agree i like that a lot
there was just so much but i i do want
to uh give major props like
new characters that came in
uh
uh whoever played bugs who was that
she's brilliant um
yeah i mean i thought she was fantastic
i was like oh i'm gonna call her jessica
hedwig that's it yeah yeah i'm gonna
follow her career she is amazing
yeah she she was incredible she was inc
uh
super captivating to watch she held her
own
um
carrion moss is just she was incredible
i i i just i loved it i realized patrick
harris was in the movie oh patrick
harris was all up in the movie yeah no
the guy who's in uh mine hunter i don't
remember his name he's also that's where
i know him from yeah and then yaya who
is in um
the watchmen the hbo series yeah
they were all really really good um i
unfortunately like patrick harris have a
scene where he holds his hand on neo's
chest and goes he's afraid he does
because that's what i want he's good
though
um
yeah i know i don't spend as much time
reading angry criticism of things
anymore so i don't feel like i can
advocate for the that
group of people for what they were
saying accurately which feels like it's
better for my mental health but i did
try to look over some
like metacritic commentary and it is
generally like
it does have a 68 which is 68 positive
it's not great um but like one of the
most negative ones says a waste of time
and money for fans of the series it's a
betrayal that deserves to be ignored and
forgotten as soon as possible the rehash
story is convoluted which i don't agree
with i think it's quite simple um
existing under the guise that if you
can't follow along it's because you
aren't smart enough to understand well i
didn't read that part before i said the
first part
and then mildly original but bailly
inspiring the ruby reboot proves that
cover movies and unnecessary franchise
rebots are generally a bad idea and i
don't know i feel like i'm looking at it
as again i i didn't love it but i feel
like i'm looking at
at it as a love story
and i feel like it executes that very
well oh yeah it's almost to the point of
being ham-fisted in in some ways
was that a professor from ucla film
school who was that it's just three
different reviews 69 from des moines got
it
i i look do you remember the trinity
neo love theme he's very nice don dave
[ __ ] just nearly punch your microphone
about it i know seriously you're next
alana uh the uh
that's the ghost of jet lag mike [ __ ]
not a uh not a big melody score but it
has the very nice you know
[Music]
i don't know if that's in that score at
all but it's prominently featured in the
third i think so
um as like their their theme and i
remember that being a surprise because
it it's really prominent towards the end
of revolutions and remember at some
point going back to the first one and
realizing holy [ __ ] that was actually
like given a tiny little appearance in
the first
film i always loved those little
structural moments like the
like in um
lord of the rings the
[Music]
which is the theme for like minis tirith
and the people of gondor that that
actually appears during one scene of
fellowship it's all over it's in like
every freaking queue he beats it to
death in return of the king and i
remember being blown away when i
realized
that he actually had worked that out in
advance where is it
here's a question though
do you feel that that is
a composer
come
thinking down the line so i know where
these stories are going therefore i'm
going to hold on to this and set up this
or the director perhaps doing this i'm
going to set up this cue this music cue
to be the theme or do you feel that it's
more
hey remember that thing that we did what
if we made it their theme which do you
think happens more often
i think uh
more often than not it's the latter and
i would bet money in the case of the
lord of the rings and in the case of the
matrix that that's th that's what
happened that because they didn't even
know there were going to be more movies
whereas lord of the rings
howard shore got that job because he
showed up to the set in new zealand with
an annotated copy of the book and he
knew everything about the stories and
was basically like you would be stupid
to not hire me wow and
uh so you know because they had already
made offers to
at least james horner and they'd been
turned down and because the scale of the
job was so large it was like you don't
get to do anything for the next three
years
and other composers you know that john
williams james horner they they they
couldn't just say no to their to the
spielberg's of their life for that long
and so howard shore was in a unique
situation that he was really well known
but didn't have quite that gravy train
although he did manage to sneak one
david cronenberg movie in the middle of
the lord of the rings trilogy called
spider which always impressed me but he
was basically man the one with ray fines
yep yeah he did that between two of the
lord of the rings scores have you ever
seen that alana
i'm not it is his most uncomfortable
movie he smokes the entire movie
it is
that's all
yeah all of his movies are uncomfortable
but um but anyway yeah so howard shore
he was clearly like deeply a nerd for
the material writing music in elvish and
all this kinds of stuff and so it was no
surprise that they used that theme it's
when boromir to answer your question
it's when boromir is talking about his
father uh and like holding the line back
at ministereth during the fellowship of
the or the you know council of elrond
seen around the ring that makes sense
you know sort of right before the one
does not simply walk into mordor my
guess would have been it was it was him
in aragon talking at night in rivendell
because it's just the two of them of men
yeah it is it is nearly that scene but
it is during boromir's sort of speech
you hear the solo french horn do that
melody and then you don't really hear it
again until the third film and i
remember that was
so
i i suspect it's not that case in the
matrix him featuring that little tune he
probably just wrote something that felt
like this is capturing you know that
relationship because obviously
you know she has that whole monologue to
him when the the
the sentinels are ripping apart the ship
and you know neo has to rise and
overcome having just been shot to death
at the end of the first movie
um like it there's there's
there's justification for this melody i
have to go back and remember the exact
moment where it appears
um
and i it's possible that i'm got my
wires crossed but i remember being like
that's the theme that's like the little
hint of that little tune do you think i
could google that
is that googleable i think you could
google it how would i look that up
if you set your mind to it you can do it
uh
when
i have when
i can
matrix
i'm going to try the the bethel style
approach to solving this look look
behind
how are you everybody makes it sound
like the matrix resurrections actually
has a new neo and trinity theme
which is interesting
um
in any case most of the reviews here do
seem to largely be pretty positive i
just know some people hated it but i
unfortunately don't know why um i'm
always okay with people disliking things
uh they did give me low expectations
but uh yeah it's the full conductor
we've talked about this before i just
don't care what people think no it's
fine i care like what austin thinks to
care what you think as far as like oh my
gosh you should see this because a
relationship with you but anybody else
that that comes on and says
i'm going to tell you why you shouldn't
watch this movie no you can't do that
you can't be telling other people how to
feel get it get that out of here you
can't do anything tell that to that's
that's the whole
premise of twitter and reddit right now
let me tell you how you should feel it's
true
one of my favorites is sometimes people
like uh i got it on my i sort of did a
review of the resident evil movie and
people were like your opinion sucks
here's what i think and why it's correct
and i was like
or they sorry they would start with this
is just your opinion and then they'd
list their opinion as though it was fact
and i would just reply with this is just
your opinion i don't understand
why we need to
can we not just disagree that's okay um
but yeah i'm glad you liked it troy
because i was concerned that you would
be one of the people who are in the camp
who hated it because
and i think that there's a lot of it
where like you did with spider-man you
go okay this is what it is it doesn't
need to be anything for me can i just
accept it for what it is and it didn't
that movie didn't deliver what is that
it's not a pizza it wasn't here because
you specifically ordered specific
ingredients i walked and i was like i
didn't like it didn't care for it and i
i can kind of point out some things that
i i feel objectionally were or
objectively were were this
but
i didn't it it's not up to my my
prescription and and sometimes it's not
the people's taste and that's fine it
sure is that goes across the board for
everything
uh i also got some more context on lilly
wachowski not being part of it
so it's part that she said i got out of
my transition in 2016 and was just
completely exhausted because we had made
cloud atlas and jupiter ascending and
the first season of sense8 back to back
to back
we were posting one and prepping the
other one at the exact same time which
is nuts that's super impressive um so
you're talking about three ones
three 100 plus days of shooting for each
project and so coming out and just being
completely exhausted my world was like
falling apart to some extent
so i needed time away from the industry
i needed to reconnect with myself as an
artist and i did that by going back to
school and painting and stuff and then
the part that i had heard
is she goes on to say lana had come up
with this idea for another matrix movie
and we had this talk and it was actually
we started talking about it in between
our dad and our mom dying which was five
weeks apart
there was something about the idea of
going backward and being a part of
something that i had done before that
was expressly unappealing i didn't want
to have gone through my transition and
gone through this massive upheaval in my
life the sense of loss from my mom and
dad to want to go back to something i
had done before and sort of walk over
old paths that i had walked in felt
emotionally unfulfilling and really the
opposite like i was going back to living
these old shoes in a way i didn't want
to do that and i believe lana said that
she felt the opposite that she felt like
going back would be comforting to her so
i respect that
i not only do i respect that i really
commend both of them for being able to
be so forthcoming and aware you know
what i mean i i feel and also a lot of
people assume that there was drama and
it's like no two people can just not do
something together and it doesn't have
to be dramatic
sure right like we automatically
inextricably tie them
nope
i i i feel like um
i can forgive that though to a degree if
everything was branded as the wachowskis
for ages you know like that it was
definitely a team effort for up until
now i guess i think
brothers to do something to you know
together and but the thing that i i is
to me uh especially
revealing is that um
you've heard about post-production blues
and there are there's something about
you know posting
being in post and prepping at the same
time people like oh my gosh it's such a
um hard thing to do i understand the
appeal because what you do it's like
it's drinking to avoid the hangover and
sometimes what you need to do is is you
need to
finish post rap
and sit in silence and not have anything
else to do to grieve the thing that you
just made you just
it grew up and it left home it's like if
somebody had if like you know people
grew up and their kids grew up and they
left and went up to college and then
they immediately adopted a kid like hold
on a second appreciate this time that
you have and i think that they're one of
the reasons why she may have been even
more exhausted
is because there were now two things
that she she didn't properly grieve the
thing that she just three of them i
think it's three that's yeah cloud atlas
jupiter ascending and sense8 but i think
she said she was posting while they were
prepping since
so it's that you you can rap on
something and be like man it sucks i
mean i've talked to so many filmmakers
directors game developers whatever that
a lot of them said they hate shipping a
game
because it's just they know that it's
it's it's no longer in their hands and
there's such a a there's a there's a
morning to it that happens
um but it's a it's a very healthy thing
because clearly those people go on to
make more things if they don't then
maybe it's something they should have
done in the first place working in games
media was always a little bit like that
after e3 because you spent half of your
year preparing tirelessly for e3 um and
then weirdly that got better because
comic-con started ramping up immediately
afterwards right so you'd have like a
week and then you're back into it you
know i had someone message me
this week
um who was like
hey
uh assuming ragnarok is coming out this
year
um enjoy crunch you're gonna love it and
that is not to suggest that i've worked
any crunch i have not um but i i was
like was that a sarcastic comment and
they were like no no they were like no
no i fully mean that it's like
one of the best things i've ever done
and i was like wow that's i've never
heard anybody admit that before um i
guess because it can be problematic and
unhealthy in some ways but i'm like i've
enjoyed working crunch at other jobs for
sure where it feels like everybody is
working together on something and i
totally don't want to romanticize it but
it was just very interesting to have
somebody who works in gamedev and has
for i think it's like
almost 20 years message me and be like
you're gonna love it it's like wow no
one ever says that
i don't
feel that anyone who is unhealthy
should
um who who has potential heart risk and
has not trained should go out and run a
marathon
it is inadvisable for anybody to go and
willingly volunteer
to run any length 10k
uh
15k 20k to to do an incredible you know
distance of running if you've never
trained for it um and if you've not made
sure that medically you are sound
that being said being in a position
where i did do that i did a half
marathon 13.1 that's all i need to do
don't need to do the 26.2
um that's so brutal
but i know people that have done 50 and
there is a great sense of accomplishment
where you look back and you said i just
ran 13 miles it's also that's fairly bad
for your body like marathons my um
[Music]
what is his relation to me i guess it's
my cousin's husband
i don't know what that relationship is
um he does multiple every year
multiple marathons and is always like
afterwards
i can't do it anymore because running a
marathon is so bad for your body so
doing one you have to space out the next
one people can do them multiple times
but they're so bad for your body that
said i will continue to do five every
year and i didn't know that even a
marathon is literally bad for you
physically it's bad for your joints it
can be bad for you in a whole bunch of
ways but he's like but i love doing it i
love training for them i love getting
them done but you have to recover
afterwards otherwise you will injure
yourself
i think that it can be damaging if you
are not properly trained and i think
that there anything you obsess over can
can always have damage
any working out is damaging to your body
like you sh you know if you don't want
to damage your body don't pick up
anything that is heavier than what you
can easily do because that is damaging
your body this the definition of what
working out is
what my trainer said
don't think that exactly hold on let me
let me explain
but my trainer said i think you
shouldn't i think we should just live in
ignorance
the one thing that i said that might
that my trainer says that i love so much
is like you don't go to the you don't
get strong in the gym
this is where we destroy your body
you get
strong as you sleep you get strong as
you rest so it has nothing to do with i
can do two a days and and you know party
at night it's like that's not working
out is it must be coupled with proper
diet and rest and hydration
um so i think it's just a semantics
thing though i think but it's a it's a
very important distinction there's a
difference between damaging your body i
understand what you're saying but
there's there's things that i i could
not
do that would be damaging that were not
oh my body can't do that as opposed to
lack of strength and and pointing out
and this goes across the board this has
nothing to do with just like hey a
working out bro in the gym and protein
whatever this is talking about how do i
stay healthy and mobile for the rest of
my life
and i don't believe in
that there there's science that shows it
has nothing to do with just you have a
bad back now it's like no you have lack
of strength and you need to do that but
that takes damaging your body it takes
tearing muscles so they can be rebuilt
and forming new mind and muscle
connections so that can feel damaging
but it also does not mean that you're
doing permanent damage i don't i think
there's a difference between stimulating
the muscle and therefore causing it to
you know
grow for lack of a better word uh you
know to to gain strength and to develop
that's semantics though stimulating and
tearing
no no but but tearing and damaging means
that like you are it is undergoing some
kind of physical trauma
yeah that's what weightlifting is that's
what weightlifting is you do you
probably again
i think i take issue with the word
damaging but it is tearing okay i only
take issue with the word damaging which
is semantics because we read that as
injury you're not injuring your muscles
but you are tearing them
correct
yeah i would look at and say there's a
difference between maybe i have a blind
spot in my my knowledge here but you
don't know what you should talk about
that is literally what weightlifting is
yeah you have to test everything
i'm shocked austin wintry uh is not the
weightlifting expert on the podcast
eccentric movement especially eccentric
moving that's where most of the micro
tears happen
you've got fast switch and slow twitch
muscles and when you do those micro
tears your body goes we need to build
which is why you have to increase your
intake of protein so that your body can
produce more i mean that all makes sense
i'm definitely willing to acknowledge
that i could be wrong here it certainly
feels intuitively wrong
that
you are
damaging it but but i certainly would
agree
that
the
that lifting is not where you build the
strength it's sort of like the reaction
by your body to that process which is
why
proper
muscle building is a really long term
uh we just never thought that we'd get
into this on this position i was i was
setting this up as saying getting into
crunch right yeah
if if you are in a situation i'm not
going to get into crunch culture at all
because there's just no way i can
contribute to that conversation
effectively but i can't say don't sign
up to do a marathon if you're not
trained and it don't expect a marathon
to be easy it is hard so somebody going
it's like hey you're going it's going to
suck and you're getting on the other
side of this you're going to feel very
great that's awesome but there's a
there's a the difference and i wish mike
was here for this conversation could he
he could speak well i know what mike
would say he would say um
uh don't worry
crunch uh don't make your team crunch
um
you know make sure that you plan
accordingly so people don't have to do
that and there is a world where you
cannot
i agree and i think there's also there's
a there's a predetermined amount i knew
how long i was running it wasn't just
like you're just going to continue to
run for forever that's true and no one
told me how fast i had to run i could
take as little or as long as i wanted
yeah but the the distance was was um
predetermined so i guess that's that's
what i'm saying
but i understand like doing something
hard
yeah man there's a good tired at the end
of the day it's like you did something
but especially as a group like when you
do something collectively and like you
know ign's e3 teams were massive and it
was really hard and everyone was working
incredibly hard gamedev's a whole other
thing though like
working with hundreds of people who are
just so good at what they do
will never stop
feeling cool to me hopefully like i'm
still at a point where somebody sends an
email
and if i don't know what a term means
i'll just ask them
i'll just reply and be like what does
this mean and every single time that i
have done that i've gotten a detailed
response from somebody who's clearly
excited to tell me
information about this one thing only
they know and i think it's it's just so
[ __ ] awesome that i'm like i just
have access to be a teacher to you being
super informed and passionate now like
like somebody recently sent a bunch of
gifts to explain they were like well
this means this and here's how it looks
in in development it's [ __ ] all like
i would pay for this it's so so so cool
and like every game studio is just full
of people who who are so specifically
informed and enthusiastic about what
they do and it's it's awesome it's man
it's like that great it's like school of
hard knocks i hate to use such a cliche
term but it's so true it's like being on
a job and like now it counts it's not
just an academic experiment but like
you're being paid to do this
i've never met someone
even the most especially the most
arrogant who didn't love being a teacher
and go can you show me how to do that
they love it it's great so
i i'm i'm a little short on time but i
did kind of in in speaking with this i
wanted to share something with you guys
because i've talked about it before
i'll just say i did find it i did find
it at the very at the very end uh it is
the moment that when neo is unconscious
in the chair
and the moment that trinity
uh kisses him well there's a whole build
up yes the oracle told me blah blah blah
and then the actual moment she kisses
him you'll see
uh violas and horns together it's super
underdeveloped
did you get your nails done
but that right there in g minor going
that's the first glimpse of that i knew
i wasn't crazy but it's it's not it it's
really undercooked compared to where he
where he takes it so anyway i'm glad i
found it because i've been sitting here
reading through the whole last queue of
the film and being like i swear i'm not
crazy i think that um
hans
with batman begins who uh
intentionally did
uh
it's like the batman theme that is in
those movies is incomplete
and begins so it's like it intentionally
doesn't finish so yeah there's a whole
youtube video
yeah i've heard sort of there's
conflicting uh there's conflicting uh
tales there uh oh that's not direct from
from him well no i've just heard him say
two different things that feel like they
don't quite align it's like one they
didn't feel like both could be true
interesting
but what were you about to say troy
since we're we're about to be out of
time here oh i was just gonna cut you
off it was all good in in the spirit of
of uh talking about doing the hard thing
and and uh
and
being faced with adversity i i think
i've shared with you guys before like i
i had one specific um event where i
um
i was scuba diving and i had a panic
attack underwater like 85 feet
and that has that has kind of like
stayed with me and i've there's a great
podcast andrew huberman called the
hubermann lab as a professor from
stanford and he he talks about
the neurology behind a lot of emotional
especially trauma and and
and fear and so i've really been kind of
digging into that and wanting to
overcome it and one of the things they
consistently talk about is exposure
therapy
so uh i've been having some it's oddly
we talk about you know doing damage to
your body whatever but i've been having
these perpetual back problems and so um
sunday doing absolutely nothing and just
bent over to pick up a tablet back
quote went out and i've been i've been
dealing with that ever since and trying
to do everything that i can and and some
of the tools that i've learned since
then to kind of help
but finally to the point i was like all
right i'm going to see if there's
anything else
that is going on that i don't know about
and knowledge is power information is
key and so i went and scheduled an mri
now
if you don't know what mra is
magnetic resonance imaging they put you
into basically a space tube and magnets
move around your body and takes a
picture
that for me for someone who can now say
that i i struggle with claustrophobia um
it's it's like the worst
scenario for me and so i walked in and i
said hey i just need to know just i've
done one of these before um how long
were talking about like 15 minutes she
was like yeah yeah 15 minutes i was like
okay great she goes twice
i went
she goes well you know if you want to
take a break we can take a break she's
going to come back in you'll do these
two rounds of 15 minutes i was like okay
15 minutes does not seem like that long
unless you are surrounded with a plastic
tube two inches from your face and i
said do you have the panic button she
goes yeah you have claustrophobia it's
like a little bit
she goes yeah yeah you'll have this
shoes like would you like mirror glasses
that sounds terrible and she said
there's actually these mirror glasses
that instead of looking up and all you
can see is just this you know dome of
plastic that's surrounding you you can
actually look and you'll see everyone
can see me and see the room and i was
like [ __ ] yeah she was doing headphones
i was like yes i was hoping i could have
someone's like could you please put on
especially chopin it's really great
she's like absolutely so she found some
classical music for me put me in and uh
and i went
and i ended up counting down 15 times uh
60 to zero and just kind of keeping that
pace and boy my mind did everything that
it could
uh to
to put me back into the situation of
that fear and that trauma and it was it
was really really hard i was sweating i
could feel my heart pounding i i had the
panic button in my hand the entire time
uh and then next thing i know she's
pulling me out she's like you did it
it's round one do you want to do it
again and the opportunity to pull out
and go no i'm i'm i'm gonna cash out now
and i said yeah let's do it and the
second round was far far easier
so uh i just want to encourage you that
there's if anybody has any kind of like
uh fear or trauma or or something that
they're dealing with always always
always always always do it the reason
why i could do that was because i was in
the direct supervision of a medical
professional and they they knew what
that machine was they knew what my
situation going in was there's a lot of
background information they had going in
so everybody felt safe moving into that
it was just going to be hard so don't
ever do something like getting therapy
even with a friend talking with a friend
is incredibly helpful but if you've
experienced any kind of fear of trauma
or anything and you feel that you need
help with that i just want to encourage
you do the hard thing
um and and find find a safe place and a
safe way for you to do that but there's
nothing wrong with ever just being
exposed that same kind of
fear from a safe distance to help you
kind of overcome that because it is
possible the beauty of our brains is
that the very thing that triggers our
fear is the exact it's the double-edged
sword the same thing as how we can fix
that fear so anyway just want to so i
guess the headline is troy uh suggests
non-stop crunch
that's right that's i can't wait for the
comments listen i strongly agree but
also um my number one fear is spiders
i want to get into that with you i'm
going to send you the link to this this
podcast there is there is there is
something
to this podcast we discuss
um the huberman lab check it out talk
about fear and trauma because he talks
specifically about spiders it's
fantastic
i tried exposure therapy um
and it didn't help made it worse there's
there's also something inherent to all
all creatures on the planet that have a
predisposition against spiders i've
heard that also
yeah there's just something about it
everyone's like because they've been
around spiders spiders have like 400
million years of evolutionary history
they predated the dinosaurs they've
survived multiple mass extinctions
they're like
my whole body is covered in chills just
talking about it and i have this thing
where whatever they're present and in my
brain i then feel like spiders are
crawling all over me
so i will like be hitting myself for
hours just be like oh i also am very
scared of crabs and i think it's because
they are spider-like
yeah totally i always get people be like
they're not the spiders in the sea i'm
not scared of them hurting me i'm not
scared of being hurt i'm scared of a
scuttering thing that disappears in my
[ __ ] house i would eat a crab i would
not eat a spider
i can't eat either
i gotta run
we've left me in a dark place here
that's fine
yeah troy condones
troy
condones
troy have you seen spiderman
no i'm gonna go i'll i'll see it do it
i'll watch it i finished arcane austin
also i thought
i thought the first episode episode was
really bad
don't you dare don't you dare
i did
oh my god i thought it was really bad
we're gonna get we're gonna get letters
i didn't even introduce the show troy
can you wait with me while i intro the
show
hi everyone
this is play watch listen troy may have
stopped recording um austin's already
gone uh well you know the show mike's
not here okay bye